Moitas Gracias eh, por desearnos falar, señorías D.O. PP,
muchísimas Gracias.
¿Qué Tal ante democrático?
Es normal que ustedes estén preocupados y preocupadas
porque saben que en este país
hay 1 mayoría que quiere cambios.
Van a tener que decidir entre dudas,
opciones y e o que bostede, cesa el he sido Presidente,
o que por Primera vez ceñan a 1 presidenta
más libres para defender los intereses de este país,
eso que está en shogo en este momento,
o que continúe 1 gobierno D.O. partido popular
que está facendo que galiza vaya menos
porque nos deis aún a galiza maíz
pequeña en todos los ámbitos,
con menos sanidades,
con menos educación,
con menos oportunidades para gente moza, ¿eh?
Non es culpa de este país, no,
no es culpa de 1 gobierno
que non está a altura de los galegos
de das galegas
y que nos está dejando atrás.
La elección,
señorías D.O. partido popular está muy Clara,
o seguir con 1 gobierno dopartido popular,
o por 1 gobierno liderado por lo Venega
que VA y traballar para devolverle a esperanza
y o futuro os galegos y as galegas